how did he not know that this was gonna
happen everyone who's famous gets their
videos chopped up he had to have some
sense that this was gonna happen and the
second criticism is from people who say
wasn't this his business model you know
there was the guardian i pulled a quote
from the guardian and it says his rapid
surge to fame was not by chance evidence
obtained by the observer shows that
followers of tate are being told to
flood social media with videos of him
choosing the most controversial clips in
order to achieve maximum views and
engagement so the criticism is that you
know through hustler university and
through the business model that he
established one of the incentives was
for these affiliates to repost content
so how did he not see that this was
going to happen what is your reaction to
that yeah i and i once again i was just
one of the things i was critical of him
on what my show yesterday was uh the
guys who are the the tate army are
basically his cam girls more or less
um i've heard it put that way now if you
don't if you don't know anything about
their history that's how they sort of
came up in the business uh prior to only
fans they were guys who ran cam girls
and pretty much they skimmed off the top
and they would put the girls out there
sometimes they would be the ones sort of
doing the hustling behind the scenes
it's not unlike most uh only fans uh
girl like the most popular only fans
girls today are not running their own
channel it's the guy behind them that's
helping them sort of promote this and
she's the talent that's on that's on the
screen they were doing that long before
there was and only fans and so this
model is sort of like well we're going
to have other it's not i i know patrick
that david is gets kind of bristles at
this it's not multi-level marketing it's
affiliate marketing so you join hustlers
university for 49 for 50 a month okay
and as a as a benefit of that if you po
if you're not saying you have to but if
you repost you start a new channel that
it's an unaffiliated channel with uh
with tates on youtube and you
rebroadcast or you do derivative work of
those of those broadcasts that they have
then you will get kickbacks as a result
of that it will pay for itself and they
essentially there's a sort of a
financial incentive for
uh his his fans to go and produce this
stuff and that's really how he owned the
algorithm on on youtube he's the first
guy that i know who has successfully
gamed the youtube algorithm by
essentially flooding the uh flooding the
the channels or flooding a youtube with
his with his followers and so as and of
course this was sort of a downstream
thing so if they were part of the
university that he was getting that
money from these guys but then as a
result they were getting they were
getting affiliate dollars by
rebroadcasting this stuff and that's
that's how it worked for these guys now
the problem with that of course is that
you draw a lot of attention to yourself
and no and you know what happens then is
you get like dave portnoy like calling
you and you get like tucker carlson
calling you and suddenly now you can't
go on youtube without seeing something
in your impressions about andrew tate
that's how people know this that's why
why uh high school teachers are
complaining about their you know middle
school and high school kids are like
repeating the same kind of things that
they hear in a andrew tate buzz clip
which is by the way a 30 second 45
second buzz clip on twitter on tick tock
so the same thing
that you can it's kind of hard to
complain about the business model of how
you're taken out of context in a
30-second
buzz clip
when at the same time that's your
marketing strategy through the guys who
are rebroadcasting your own your own
material in the form of 30-second
45-second you know tick-tock videos so
now
as a result he is the most googled guy
on planet earth uh people who would
never have even known him or heard his
name before want to talk to him i'm
actually surprised he hasn't been on joe
rogan yet yeah
but that's pretty much how how how it
worked and that's how he gained that
algorithm and i i i had a discussion uh
not too long ago with i think it was
adam and patrick i said this i said the
the way that he has managed to do this
is
he has like i said he's he's owns the
algorithm and he's the first guy that
has ever like learned how to do the how
to get into the impressions and work his
way up through that
by getting a mass of people to sort of
push his material i i compared it to
this i don't know if you remember this
back in 2021 there was a guy there's a
group i think it was a read a group or a
user group of investors and what they
did was they put all their money into
like game stop and they put their money
into amc theaters back then so that they
could sort of screw over the wall street
big guys who knew that this those stocks
were going to take a hit and so they
were putting put options against it so
all these guys got together and said
okay here's what we're going to do we're
going to buy up game stop and we're
gonna buy up amc theaters right now and
we're gonna we're so we can stick it to
these wall street guys and some guys
made a lot of money off of it but what
they had done is they played by the
rules they played successfully by the
rules and they got enough people to go
and buy those stocks to uh to offset the
wall street guys who are betting against
those two stocks it's very much the same
the same kind of dynamic you get enough
guys to get on board to say okay guys
get together here we got a hundred
thousand dudes we're gonna we're gonna
rebroadcast tate and keep going and keep
going and that's how we're gonna own the
the algorithm they're still playing by
youtube's rules right but now
youtube says no no no no you don't get
to those you you figured out the code
you broke the code right you figured out
the code in the matrix and the algorithm
but now we don't want you to do that
anymore and that's why tick tock bands
him and all of his sub accounts and all
the people who are rebroadcasting his
his uh his material because
it's that dangerous it's that he's the
most dangerous man he's the number one
yeah he's the on the fbi's most wanted
list as a result of simply putting out
this message out there it would be
different if it was something that was
like seditious or it was something that
was like pro
you know conservative thought or
whatever but it's not it's about it's
essentially red pill material it's
essentially the manosphere and that's
what they're threatened by yeah it's
fascinating and i think one of the you
know just having gone through media
myself i remember when i first started
doing television i really was thinking
about everything i was saying very
carefully you know
kind of learning what it meant to have
an audience and that evolved and one of
the the takeaways for me was that i you
know i don't know if he was ready for it
to blow up so big and so fast
i mean it's just it's it's too much for
many to even think about you know like
how does this just all of a sudden
happen and i don't i don't know that he
was necessarily ready for what was
coming his way because there's a lot of
people that wanted to capitalize they
wanted to make money off of the fact
that he was rising and then there's a
lot of people who who really stay
attuned to
someone who is on the rise and you know
a lot was brought up about the big
brother years and that video that popped
up that wound up being like a kink video
where there were two consenting adults
but it rubbed people the wrong way and
that wound up being why he was dismissed
and i said you know he wasn't banned
then why wasn't he banned then because
he was he was really nobody right he's
being banned now because this is a guy
who does have an army behind him has a
lot of guys that agree with his content
has a lot of people that have
listened to the long form interviews and
they're not just listening exclusively
to these little sound bites and now he's
he's a problem for he's a lot i think
he's a threat to a lot of movements he's
a threat to the modern way of living
he's a threat to modern feminism he's a
threat to
a lot of institutions that you know want
to preserve their right to ban and their
right to censor and this guy's just out
there saying anything you know so i
think he's a threat to a lot of the
status quo in many respects i want to i
want to get to a part of this um where
he talks a little bit about let me throw
one more thing out here really quick
because because this will still put a
period to that that whole section right
there yeah when i was doing my show
yesterday i usually start with sort of
intro videos and nice little you know
breakdowns one of the videos i showed
yesterday was this guy and i don't know
who the guy's channel was so i apologize
the guy was going around central park
and he had his cell phone he was asking
random like young people gen z
people and old and maybe slightly older
um what they thought of andrew tate and
so he was going to ask these girls he
was asking you know the guys that were
with other girls and uh damn near every
one of them except for the last dude
just hated him and every single point
they brought up about like why they
didn't like him and they i mean to the
point where they like really wanted to
like you know punch him or hurt him in
some way um the reason why they had come
up with this is because they had seen
those 30-second buzz clips that's all
their impression of the hymn was and
that's all it took for him for this guy
who's going around central park you know
doing these on the street kind of videos
and and asking these people and that's
all it took to get to a level of anger
and a level like to get that outrage out
of these out of these young people who
had probably only seen those 30-second
buzz clips of him talking about whatever
they had never gone into like the
long-form videos like when he did the
the show with sean reynolds and some
other stuff as well but it's that's that
right there like after i after i put
that up i go man that's actually pretty
scary
well yeah and it's indicative of the
times right as you were saying before i
mean i don't think we're in times where
people are inquisitive where they're
curiou they're lazy people are lazy and
they look and they want to be mad all
the time someone's always the enemy you
know they rather they'd rather get upset
and pound and scream that
then have a conversation so you know
he's also operating at a time when
people have no attention span when all
these mediums are active that edit and
the sound bites and you know it's it's
not it's not a great time for someone
who does have controversial things to
say but really benefits from a long-form
interview which he does because i've
i've watched them and i see how i really
looked and i even i even tried to crop
some and said wow well if i took just
this and this i would have this reaction
but if i hear all of this
i still disagree but it's a very
different reaction than what i would
have had so but it takes effort right
not everyone's gonna sit here and do
what i just did because they don't care
they'd rather just watch 30 seconds be
mad and go on with their day right to
the next thing they can be mad about so
i want to pull something uh it's what i
call i call this in the past outrage
brokership
i come from politics rolo everyone's
outraged and usually you know why you
know why they're outraged in politics
because they watch cable news and cable
news it operates in the same exact way i
worked in it you got three minutes you
got three guests you're all trying to
get a word in nobody accomplishes
anything and then everyone leaves angry
it's a business model it is a business
model and it's successful for a lot of
these places if you like the short clip
you can catch another one here or you
can catch the full episode right here
[Music]